WAI CHEE DIMOCK: Last time,
on Tuesday,
we were talking about
the use of
the word "nigger" by
various people--
in context, sometimes trying to
be trivializing, sometimes
obviously agonized, but trying
to disguise that fact.
But sometimes by one's
neighbors,
sometimes by oneself.
But always in kind of
a nontrivial usage.
So today, we're turning to the
other side of the phenomenon
and thinking about what it
means to inhabit that
adjective, "nigger" --
what it means to embrace
that as one's identity.
At least the Joe Christmas part
of the story of Light in
August is really about what it
means for somebody to choose
to be black.
So it's very important to
recognize that this is a
volitional act.
It is a decision, active
conscious decision.
But in that sense, it's also
about someone poised on two
contrary possibilities.
Joe Christmas could be either
black or he could be white.
So the either or possibility
is something that actually
becomes quite important
in American literature
outside of Faulkner .
So I just wanted to talk about
one other book published very
close to Light in August
by Nella Larsen.
As we can see, Nella Larsen
herself is someone who could
go either way.
She's classified as African
American, because of
the one drop rule.
So if you have the slightest
bit of African American
heritage, it classifies
as black.
So she's a black writer.
But she really could
be anything.
And in fact, she disappeared
in mid career and just
completely vanished
from public, until
she was found dead.
And there was a lot of surmises
that actually she was
passing all those years
when she disappeared.
And she wrote a novel called
Passing about two black women,
one choosing to be married to
someone who's identifiably
black, and the other choosing to
pass as a white woman, but
not succeeding, at least
not being very
happy with that decision.
So Passing, this was published
in 1929, so very close to
Light in August. And as we can
see from the book cover, it's
really about the choice of
someone who looks completely
white who is classified as
black, but who chooses to
behave as a white person, live
the life of a white person.
So in Faulkner, what, when you
see is also a kind of passing.
So let's not forget that
actually it's very much
similar to the dynamics in
Nella Larsen's Passing.
It is someone-- a man--
who looks as white as the woman
here, who actually is
initially classified as white,
but then chooses, in spite of
his outward appearance,
to embrace the
life of a black man.
So it is passing in the
opposite direction.
It is self-blackening, a white
person blackening himself.
There's no way he can blacken
his interior.
But at least he can try to
blacken his inside, try to
blacken his emotions, his choice
of companions and all
the rest of it.
So this is what Joe Christmas
decides to do when he starts
on this run down this long
street that goes from the
south to Chicago to the north.
And endless for 15 years
he's on this street.
And that's what happens to
him when he's on this
15 year-long street.
"He lived with negroes, shunning
white people, He ate
with them, slept with them,
belligerent, unpredictable,
uncommunicative.
He now lives as man and wife
with a woman who resembled an
ebony carving.
At night he would lie in bed
beside her, sleepless,
beginning to breathe
deep and hard.
He would do it deliberately,
feeling, even watching, his
white chest arch deeper and
deeper within his ribcage,
trying to breathe into himself
the dark odor, the dark and
inscrutable thinking and being
of negroes, with each
suspiration trying to expel from
himself the white blood
and the white thinking
and being.
And all the while his nostrils
at the odor which he was
trying to make his own would
whiten and tauten, his whole
being writhe and strain with
physical outrage and spiritual
denial."
So this is an incredible
instance of self-blackening,
somebody who doesn't have to
be black choosing against
everything in him--
his sense of smell, sense of
sight, his sense of touch,
everything--
against everything in him, even
though every inch of him
is revolting against being
classified as black and
associating with blacks.
That's what he chooses to do.
So it's a very, very
complicated kind of
psychology.
Usually when somebody identifies
with someone, they
usually, obviously, identify
with us because they really
like that identity.
But in this case, it's absolute
loathing of being
black, and at the same time,
deciding to be black himself.
So this is a much more complex
psychology that we've seen in
this novel.
And I think to understand
this, I think we need to
borrow the terminology from
someone who talks about what
he calls double-consciousness,
So this is W. E. B. Du Bois, a
very important thinker and
activist from the nineteenth
to basically twentieth
century.
And he wrote a book called The
Souls of Black Folk, which as
you probably forgot, came out
a while before Light in
August.
And this is what he
says about blacks.
Let's not forget he's talking
about blacks,
people who look black.
This is what he says about
the kind of complicated
consciousness that
blacks have.
"It is a peculiar sensation,
this double-consciousness,
this sense of always looking at
one's self through the eyes
of others, of measuring one's
soul by a tape of the world
that looks on in amused
contempt and pity.
One ever feels his twoness--
an American, a negro; two
souls, two thoughts, two
unreconciled strivings, two
warring ideals in one dark
body."
Keep looking at this person.
A person who looks black has no
choice but to inhabit this
double-consciousness, both to
be aware of oneself, as
oneself, having a completely
internal relation to oneself.
But at the same time, having
another's views superimposed
upon oneself, because of
the way other people
are looking at you.
So it is this doubleness, one is
looking at oneself through
involuntarily through the
eyes of other people.
But we shouldn't forget that, in
fact, Joe Christmas doesn't
look like a black man.
He looks like the male
counterpart to this white
looking woman.
So it's even more complicated
that what Du Bois is
suggesting.
It's not the
double-consciousness of an
obviously black man, but the
double-consciousness of a
white looking person, who even
though he is repelled by the
blackness, nonetheless
embraces blackness.
So it is just
double-consciousness redoubled
in terms of this degree
of complexity.
And today, I'd like to talk
about this kind of redoubled
double-consciousness
in Faulkner along
three lines of inquiry.
One is obviously the importance
of the light and
shadow, which is epitomized,
dramatized in the title.
The other is something that
we've sort of been talking
about, the relation between a
single individual and then
kind of the population of
group or multitude.
Today, that's what I'd
like to introduce.
And then something that we've
been talking about all the way
through about the question of
genre and balance between
comedy and tragedy.
Also given this configuration,
I'd like to look at three
characters--
basically the two ends of the
spectrum and a mid point.
I think that you know which two
ends of the spectrum would
be, would be Joe Christmas and
Lena Grove, one tragic figure
and the other a comic figure.
And between the two of them, I
would like to put now a third
figure, which is the
Reverend Hightower.
We've been talking about
Reverend Hightower in various
contexts, but I'd like to bring
him to bear now on the
two obvious protagonists
of Light in August.
But first starting with Joe
Christmas, I'd like to talk
about three moments--
actually, there's more than
three-- but three clusters of
moments revolving around the
act of striking a match.
It is so obviously a pattern,
a symbolic pattern revolving
around that act that I think is
really worth thinking about
the three of them in sequence
and in the interrelations.
So the first instance of
striking a match is when he's
contemplating killing Joanna.
"So Christmas lit the cigarette
and snapped the
match toward the open
door, watching the
flame vanish in midair.
Then he was listening for the
light, trivial sound which the
dead match would make when
it struck the floor.
And then it seemed to him
that he heard it.
Then it seemed to him, sitting
on a cot in a dark room, that
he was hearing a myriad sounds
of no greater volume--
voices, murmurs, whispers, of
trees, darkness, earth,
people, his own voice, other
voices evocative of names and
times and places--
which he had been conscious of
all his life without knowing
it, which were his life,
thinking God perhaps and me
not knowing that too.
He could see it like a printed
sentence, fullborn and already
dead God loves me too like the
faded and weathered letters of
last year's billboard,
God loves me too."
So it is just an incredible
passage.
And I just want to say some
obvious things about it and
then come back to it.
But there's the striking of the
match and then the dying
out of the match, so literally,
the light dying out.
But what is also interesting is
that actually as the light
dies out, then it becomes a
completely auditory moment.
It's all about the sounds that
come to Joe Christmas, the
voices he hears.
The light, the visual tableau
completely gives way to an
auditory soundscape,
basically.
And then there's this
weird kind of
emergence of his own theology.
We've been talking about the
importance of Calvin last time
and the play, the repetition of
the name Calvin in Light in
August. And here is this obvious
invocation of his
relation to God and what it
means to repeat that line,
"God loves me too."
So I just wanted to point out
these obvious things.
But because this is the last
class, I thought that it would
be good to bring back the
other two authors.
So just to the obvious detail
of God appearing on the
billboard, we actually have seen
exactly this before in
The Great Gatsby.
"and I said, 'God knows what
you've been doing, everything
you've been doing.'" --
This is Michaelis talking
to George Wilson,
Myrtle's husband --
"Standing behind him Michaelis
saw with a shock that he was
looking at the eyes of Doctor
TJ Eckleburg which had just
emerged pale and enormous from
the dissolving night."
So this is George Wilson at the
moment when he's starting
out on his quest to kill the
killer, the person who he
thinks kills his wife.
And pointing to this God
on the billboard as the
authority, invoking that
authority to justify the
mission that he's
just beginning.
The other way in which
Fitzgerald would also come
into play is obviously the
dynamic mix between the visual
and the auditory.
So this is something that we
talked about before about
Daisy's voice.
"For a moment the last sunshine
fell with romantic
affection upon her glowing face;
her voice compelled me
forward breathlessly
as I listened--
then the glow faded, each light
deserting her with a
lingering regret, like children
leaving a pleasant
street at dusk."
So the quality of voice
described in
terms of a visual image.
And finally, The Great Gatsby,
and the great self-made man in
American literature, but
described by Fitzgerald as a
quasi-religious self-making.
"The truth was that Jay Gatsby
of West Egg, Long Island,
sprang from his Platonic
conception of himself.
He was a son of God--
a phrase, which, if it means
anything, means just that--
that he must be about his
Father's business, the service
of a vast, vulgar and
meretricious beauty.
So he invented just the sort of
Jay Gatsby that a seventeen
year-old boy would be likely
to invent, and to this
conception he was faithful
to the end."
So it is very hard to ignore the
centrality of religion in
both The Great Gatsby and in
Light in August. In the case
of The Great Gatsby, the
religious language is really
used to underwrite a special
kind of self-making.
What it means to be a son of God
in the twentieth century
and in the debased
environment.
And that's the kind of
self-making that Fitzgerald is
talking of, relatively
non-racialized, even though
we've seen that there's a little
bit of race in The
Great Gatsby as well.
So against that example from
Fitzgerald, let's look one
more time at what Faulkner is
doing with exactly that
configuration, the billboard,
the interplay between the
visual and the auditory and
some invocation of God.
It seems that when the light
dies out, our only relation to
light is by way of
a dead match--
a dead match and then
it hits the ground.
And then the light goes
out completely.
And instead what we get
is all these sounds
that come to Joe Christmas.
And he becomes an involuntary,
strictly passive recipient of
sounds that come to him.
And that it really
is the central
function of Joe Christmas.
We've talked before about how
passive he is, that he's less
an actor than a recipient of
either the goodwill, or in
this case, the ill-will coming
from other people.
So he really is a blank slate,
which other people, the entire
community, can write the
collective signature.
He really is the bearer.
And it's not a very good
metaphor, considering that
we're looking at an
auditory image.
But just to switch to visual
image briefly, he's the bearer
of the collective signature
of that community.
So the transition from light to
darkness in this moment and
transition from input coming
into the eye and the input
coming through the ear is the
increasing of a dramatized
passivity of Joe Christmas.
That he's really completely a
blank page that everyone else
writes the deeds on to.
But there's this further
complication, because this is
a racialized landscape.
It seems to give us a racialized
version of a
Calvinist theology that we
talked about last time.
So I just want to think about
what it means that the first
italicized cluster was "God
perhaps and me not knowing
that too," and then "God loves
me too," repeated twice.
It's almost as if the only thing
Joe Christmas is sure
about is that God loves
other people.
That is an undisputed
statement.
So God loves other people.
Maybe God loves everyone else.
Maybe he loves me too.
So there can't be a more
devastating self-reflection,
speculation about yourself
is that everyone
else come before you.
Basically, you are an
afterthought, and maybe not
even an afterthought
in God's mind.
And even if it's an
afterthought, it is written on
God's consciousness.
It's written like those faded
and weathered letters of last
year's billboard, that
unimportant, that
negligible to God.
So it definitely is an
interesting racialized
variation on predestination.
So just it's worth going back to
Calvin for that reason and
see why it actually lends itself
so readily to this
particular negative kind
of racialization.
Last time we talked about
original sin and so on, so
this another very famous
statement coming from Calvin
on predestination.
And there's nobody more upfront
than Calvin about
predestination and
what it means.
"By an eternal and immutable
counsel God has once for all
determined those who he would
admit to salvation and those
whom He would condemn
to destruction.
To those whom He devotes to
condemnation, the gate of life
is closed by a just
irreprehensible, but
incomprehensible judgement."
So "the gate of life is closed
by a just and irreprehensible,
but incomprehensible judgment."
There's no way you
can quarrel with God.
It's his decision.
He decides that you're going
to be condemned.
It doesn't make any sense
to you, obviously,
if you're the condemned.
You can't make any
sense of it.
It's completely
incomprehensible.
But at the same time, if you're
a Calvinist you also
have to believe that
is irreprehensible.
That God has every right to
condemn you, even though from
your point of view, it seems
completely arbitrary.
So that really is the meaning
of predestination in a
particular interpretation of a
racialized context is that to
be black is to be predestined in
that particular way, always
to come second, always to be
an afterthought, and maybe
even less than an afterthought
in the mind of God.
And that is what Joe Christmas
metaphorically as well as
pragmatically chooses to, given
his own sense of being
so negligible in the world.
So that would be one
interpretation of why he
chooses to blacken himself,
even though he
doesn't have to.
So this Faulkner's version
of predestination, the
self-blackening of a
white-looking man.
It completely honors logic of
the gate of life being closed
by a just and irreprehensible,
but incomprehensible judgment.
And it's always under
the shadow of race.
So I would say that the part
of Light in August that is
associated with Joe Christmas
is very much
the regime of shadows.
And Faulkner's actually quite
heavy-handed about how often--
we've said the original
title of Light in
August was Dark House.
It could also be The Shadows of
August because so much of
the book is really
about shadows.
And the shadows tend to
emerge in context
of striking a match.
So let's go on to the next
moment, next episode of Joe
Christmas striking a match,
lighting a lamp.
This is the moment after the
dialogue that we looked at
last time of Joanna offering
to send him to study with a
black lawyer and turning over
all her funds to him.
And then the next thing that she
asks him to do is to kneel
with her and pray.
So this is all in
that context.
"'Light the lamp,' she said.
'It won't need any
light,' he said.
'Light the lamp.'
'No,' he said.
He stood over the bed.
He held the razor in his hand.
But it was not open yet.
But she did not speak again and
then his body seemed to
walk away from him.
It went to the table and his
hands laid the razor on the
table and found the lamp
and struck the match."
So very heavy-handed alienation
of Joe Christmas
from his body.
It's not Joe Christmas that's
doing the walking.
His body seemed to walk
away from him.
It's not Joe Christmas who's
laying the razor on the table.
It's his hands that is doing
it and his hands that is
striking the match to
light the lamp.
So it's just the action coming
strictly just from the
fragmented body parts.
So just highlighting the utter
passivity of Joe Christmas
himself, is as if his individual
fragmented body
parts have agency, but not
Joe Christmas as a whole.
The consequence of lighting
this lamp is this.
This is what we see when
the lamp is lit.
He actually see something
else that casts a
shadow on the wall.
"It held an old style, single
action cap-and-ball revolver
almost as long and heavier
than a small rifle.
But the shadow of it and of her
arm and hand on the wall
did not waver at all, the shadow
of both monstrous, the
cocked hammer monstrous,
back-hooked and viciously
poised like the arched head
of a snake; it did
not waver at all.
And her eyes did not
waver at all.
They were as still as
the round black ring
of the pistol muzzle.
But there was no heat
in them, no fury.
But he was not watching them.
He was watching the shadowed
pistol on the wall; he was
watching the cocked shadow of
the hammer flicked away."
It's almost as if it's
irrelevant, but it's
actually going on.
The most important thing
is the play of that
shadow on the wall.
But we do know that the shadow
is produced by that revolver.
But here we have actually the
symmetry of weaponry.
So Joe Christmas has come
fully equipped.
He has the razor in his hand,
even though it's not open.
And Joanna has the revolver
all ready.
And she thinks that
it's ready to go.
And that's what Joe Christmas
is seeing.
So this is the outcome of that
particular relationship that
is completely under the
shadow of race.
So we know Joanna would call
him, "Nigger, nigger," or
"Negro, negro, negro." That
relationship is completely
under the shadow of race.
And this is actually the earlier
moment where she talks
about race as a curse,
as an eternal curse.
It's the equivalent of
predestination in America.
"But after that I seemed to see
them for the first time
not as people, but as a thing,
a shadow in which I lived, we
lived, all white people,
all other people.
I thought of all the children
coming forever and ever into
the world, white, with the black
shadow already falling
upon them before they
drew breath.
And I seemed to see the black
shadow in the shape of a
cross."
I'm not even going to read
you the whole thing.
You guys remember
this passage.
It is very much the invocation
of the black shadow as the
modern incarnation
of the Calvinist
doctrine of original sin.
And a curse that falls upon you
before you are even born.
When you're a baby, before
you've done anything, even
before when you're in the
mother's womb that shadow is
already falling upon you.
So it's a very, very
extreme version of
the Calvinist theology.
And right here, we also see it
not only as theology, but as
dramatic action as the shadow
of that pistol on the wall.
And we now know the final
moment of Joe Christmas
striking the match.
"Then he paused, and he struck
a match and examined the
pistol in the puny
dying glare.
The match burned down and went
out, yet he still seemed to
see the ancient thing with its
two loaded chambers; the one
upon which the hammer had
already fallen and which had
not exploded, and the other upon
which no hammer had yet
fallen but upon which a hammer
had been planned to fall.
'For her and for me,' he said.
His arm came back, and threw.
He heard the pistol crash once
through the undergrowth.
Then there was no sound again.
'For her and for me.'"
So this is basically the
tragic love in Light in
August. That there's
no denying the
importance of tragedy.
It depends on how much weight we
assign to the Joe Christmas
Joanna Burden section
of the novel.
If we were to give primacy
to that section, then the
symmetry of weapons--
the razor and the pistol, both
chambers loaded in Joanna's
pistol-- she really
means for the two
of them to die together.
This is the appropriate end for
a tragic narrative, even
though Joe Christmas doesn't
die at the end.
Nonetheless, the stage is really
set for that particular
tragic outcome.
So there's really not
a whole lot more.
It couldn't be any
other outcome.
There could be no other ending
for Joe Christmas and Joanna.
Either one of them had to die or
the two of them had to die.
But Faulkner can't really think
of any other ending for
the two of them.
But thank God they're not the
only ones in Light in August.
So we're beginning to move to
someone, towards the other
side of the spectrum.
And actually a very interesting
transitional
figure of someone who's at
midpoint between Joe Christmas
and Lena Grove is Hightower.
And actually the image of the
light and shadow and kind of
contrast between light and
shadow is also the visual
landscape in which Hightower
is situated.
So this is the moment when Byron
Bunch and Joe Christmas
grandparents-- at this
point we sort of know
that they are related.
But basically Byron Bunch going
to Hightower and begging
him to tell a lie so that Joe
Christmas can have an alibi.
So Byron says it's really your
word against Joe Brown's.
If you would just say that he
was with you that night, that
will be better, stronger
evidence than anything coming
from Joe Brown.
So Hightower could have told a
lie, and the lynching wouldn't
have happened.
But this is what he does.
"Because now Hightower is
shouting, 'I won't do it!
I won't!' with his hands raised
and clenched, his face
sweating, his lip lifted upon
his clenched and rotting teeth
from about which the long
sagging of flabby and
puttycolored flesh falls away.
Suddenly his voice rises higher
yet. 'Get out!' he
screams. 'Get out of my house!
Get out of my house!' Then he
falls forward on to the desk,
his face between his extended
arms and his clenched first.
As, the two old people moving
ahead of him, Byron looks back
from the door, he sees that
Hightower has not moved, his
bald had and his expanded
clenchfisted arms lying full
in the pool of light from
the shaded lamp."
So this particular visual image
suggests that Hightower
is completely poised between
light and shadow.
There's light that is coming
from a shaded lamp.
And he's given an opportunity
actually to do something
significant in the world.
To have saved Joe Christmas
would have been a significant
deed in the life of someone who
actually has not done a
lot of significant things.
His life could have been much
more consequential, and in
fact, hasn't been all
that consequential.
So saving Joe Christmas
would have been a
consequential action.
But Hightower just cannot bring
himself to do it for all
kinds of reasons.
So we can speculate on why
he chooses not to do it.
But that is a moment when his
voice is very high as
befitting his name, Hightower.
But what that very high voice is
doing is turning away this
opportunity.
I think that all of us would
have different decisions
whether or not to lie
at that moment.
His decision is not to lie and
to allow the violence to
erupt, as everyone can see
that it's about to.
So this is the moment when he's
sort of in this light
from the poor light of
the shaded lamp.
But there's another possibility
for Hightower that
comes actually only five
pages after that.
So Faulkner actually, I would
say, is quite gentle towards
Hightower in terms of the final
place given to him in
the story, in the novel.
So we know that once before
Hightower's had
tried deliver a baby.
So we have a black woman, and
the doctor's supposed to come,
and the doctor arrives
too late.
So Hightower delivers the baby,
and the baby is dead.
And then rumors go all around
town that the baby
is his and so on.
So it turns out that he actually
get a second chance
to deliver a baby.
And of course, we know
whose baby it is.
But he gets to deliver the baby,
because the doctor also
arrives too late
a second time.
"The doctor arrived too
late this time, also.
Byron had to wait for
him to dress" --
Byron's sent to fetch
the doctor --
"Byron had to wait
for him to dress.
He was an oldish man now
and fussy, and somewhat
disgruntled at having been
awakened at this hour.
Then he had to hunt for the
switch key to his car, which
he kept in a small metal strong
box, the key to which
in turn he could not
find at once...
So when they reached the cabin
at last, the east was
primrosecolor and there was
already a hint of the swift
sun of summer.
And again the two men, both
older now, met a door of a
one-room cabin, the professional
having lost again
to the amateur, for as he
entered the door, the doctor
heard the infant cry."
So it is crucial that this is a
repetition, this is a replay
of an earlier scenario that
Faulkner ends on is this over
again, if it's a second
time or it's too
late this time also.
Also and again.
So it turns out that actually
the second time around makes
all the difference
in the world.
Because at this time Hightower
is able to deliver the baby
successfully.
This is actually the
consequential action that he
manages to do, that
is granted him.
He's not granted the whatever,
the bravery, or I don't even
know what word to use if
he had chosen to lie.
He's not granted that, whatever,
mental ability or
mental toughness to lie
for Joe Christmas.
But he is granted something
that actually is both more
uncontroversial and with an
obviously benign outcome--
to deliver a baby when the
professional doctor is too
late this time too.
So it turns out Faulkner is
giving us, not only-- and then
that is why the
double-consciousness is
redoubled or maybe redoubled
again in Light in August is
that there are two meanings
to being second.
In Joe Christmas' usage, "God
loves me too," being second
means that basically
you are nobody.
That you are nothing.
That you count for
nothing at all.
You're always going to
be an afterthought.
"God loves me too." That's what
being second-- it means
losing out and not even having
the dignity of losing out.
Just meaning being a
non-contender really, in a
field where everyone else is
going to be ahead of you.
Being a non-contender is what
being second, having the word
"too" attached to you.
But that's not the only meaning
of "too" or in the
variation, "also." So the second
time we see that in the
case of Hightower, "the doctor
arrived too late this time
also," second actually means
a second chance.
That you messed up the first
time around-- or it wasn't so
much messing up.
Some babies are just
born dead.
But I think there was
some messing up.
It wasn't a satisfied outcome.
It wasn't an acceptable outcome
to most people.
So you messed up the first time
around, you get a second
chance to do it one more time.
So being second actually
completely supports that
second usage.
And that is why, to my mind,
Hightower is such an important
midpoint between Joe Christmas
and Lena Grove is that he is
actually taking us halfway in
the direction of a much more
affirmative view of what is
possible, a much more
affirmative view of the world.
But it is important to recognize
that is actually a
completely accidental
development.
There's no reason, no logical
reason why the doctor should
arrive too late.
It's only because the doctor
arrives too late that
Hightower gets to deliver
the baby.
The doctor arrives too late
because he's old and didn't
want to be awakened up in the
middle of the night, can't
find his key to the car.
All these accidental
developments contribute to--
and the doctor, other than the
fact that he's appeared once
before, he really is an absolute
stranger to the
novel, he's such a marginal
character.
So the second chance coming to
Hightower comes to him by
virtue of the pregnancy and
the childbirth of a total
stranger, Lena Grove, and the
accidental lateness of another
accidental person, the doctor.
So we're beginning to get into
an arena where it's really not
Hightower's action alone, but
the combined action of all
these other people, many of
whom are strangers to him.
It is the combined action of all
these people that produce
an outcome.
So this is a moment to introduce
some theoretical
speculation on this point.
And James Surowiecki is a staff
writer for The New Yorker.
But five, ten years ago, he
wrote a book called The Wisdom
of Crowds, which actually
got a lot of attention
when it came out.
And his basic argument is that
the collective decision or
just the collective conjecture,
when there's a
shortage of information, the
collective conjecture, the
collective guesswork, the
aggregation of guesses from a
lot of people, that aggregation
is always going to
be closer to the truth than the
single guess of a single
individual.
So it's actually a kind
of a complicated
mathematical argument.
It's about the aggregation of
conjecture being better,
having a much higher
likelihood of being
closer to the truth.
So even though it doesn't talk
about statistic, actually it's
very statistical in its mode of
thinking, that it's about
chances and likelihood
and so on.
The other book that is also
relevant and actually has the
title Multitude is by Michael
Hardt and Antonio Negri.
It's a proven view with the
first substance of that
argument, but just one--
It's really not about what
we're talking about.
But there is one line that is
relevant to what we've been
talking about, which is about
the thinking about what the
meaning multitude could have.
For them multitude, is "the
cooperative convergence
of subjects. . .
Only the multitude through its
practical experimentation will
offer the models and determine
when and how the possible
becomes the real."
So it has some resemblance to
this Surowiecki argument,
which is that it is about
how the possible
can become the real.
And it turns out that the
collective conjecture, the
aggregation of individual
guesswork, or the aggregation
of action from a lot people
would put us in closer contact
to how the possible can
become the real.
So these are the two sort of
contemporary lines of thinking
about groups and about human
populations as opposed to
human individuals as the
agents of history.
It turns out that actually
there's also a nineteenth
century precedent
for Faulkner.
And we're so used to thinking
of The Scarlet Letter of a
condemnation as the bigotry
of Puritans.
But let's not forget actually
that Hawthorne's a very
important statement about
multitude that runs completely
contrary to our stereotypical
vision of Puritans.
"When an uninstructed multitude
attempts to see with
its eyes, it is exceedingly
apt to be deceived.
When, however, it forms its
judgment, as it usually does,
on the intuitions of its great
and warm heart, the
conclusions thus attained are
often so profound and so
unerring as to possess the
character of truths
supernaturally revealed."
It's astonishing statement from
The Scarlet Letter saying
that in fact that the great
and warm heart is not the
attribute of a single
individual.
That in fact, the human heart
in its individual embodiment
is likely to have lots and
lots of shadows in it.
And the only way that those
shadows can be relatively
deactivated is when we
think and aggregate.
I think it's a really
interesting theory.
Just offering it to you
as a possibility.
But I do think that this is what
Faulkner thinks in the
use total strangers, doctors,
people who have no relation to
one another in Light in August.
So basically, his
notion of the multitude is that
it's randomized, it's
statistical, it's populational,
it's chancy.
And this is the moment, and I
think this is the extreme
moment in Light in August right
before the killing,
actually, of Joe Christmas.
This, essentially what we get,
is -- utterly doesn't go with
the deed that follows,
but this is what
Faulkner gives us.
"In the lambent suspension of
August into which night is
about to fully come, it seems
to engender and surround
itself with a faint
glow like a halo.
The halo is full of faces.
The faces are not shaped with
suffering, not shaped with
anything, not horror, pain,
or even reproach.
They are peaceful, as though
they have escaped an
apotheosis; his own
is among them."
So I don't need to talk
any more about that.
Just that the halo is not the
halo around a single face.
It is full of faces.
And that's the reason why he
goes right back to how he
starts up, by talking about
the kindness of strangers.
And this kindness of strangers
is not even ironized by
everything that has happened in
between page one of Light
in August and the last pages
of Light in August. The
kindness of strangers, yes, it
has to recognize and take into
account and fully acknowledge
and put in the foreground the
cruelty of one's neighbors.
No question about it.
It has to encompass
all of that.
But the kindness of
strangers remains.
So he's totally happy to bring
in a person never before
mentioned in Light in
August in the last
pages of the novel.
"There lives in the eastern part
of the state a furniture
repairer and dealer who recently
made a trip into
Tennessee to get some old pieces
of furniture which he
had bought by correspondence."
A completely extraneous detail
at the end of the novel.
And the reason this furniture
dealer is in the picture
suddenly is that he's there to
witness this ongoing courtship
between Lena Grove
and Byron Bunch.
So let's see what Faulkner
thinks about marriage.
And it turns out that he
actually has given some
thought to his rival.
The relation between the two of
them is not always cordial.
So it is Faulkner writing
to Malcolm Cowley.
"I'll write to Hemingway.
Poor bloke to have to marry
three times to find out that
marriage is a failure...
Apparently man can be cured of
drugs, gambling, biting his
nails and picking his nose,
but not of marrying."
Saying this is what we're
addicted to is marriage.
It doesn't matter if you fail
1,000 times, you still want to
get married.
So given the fact, this totally
clear-eyed evaluation
of the outcome of marriage, but
also the fact that it's
just going to be an ongoing
addiction, we should not be
surprised by what comes of it at
the end of Light in August.
When we're talking about
Hemingway I want to remind you
that we've seen this kind
of structure before.
The ending of For Whom the Bell
Tolls, "He lay flat on
the brown, pine-needled floor of
the forest, his chin on his
folded arms." Beginning of the
novel, end of novel, "He could
feel his heart beating against
the pine-needled floor of the
forest."
Light in August, at the
beginning and ending.
Beginning, "although I have not
been quite a month on the
road, I'm already in
Mississippi." And ending of
Light in August, "Here we ain't
been coming from Alabama
for two months, and now it's
already Tennessee.
So it is Lena Grove counting on
the kindness of strangers
and counting on the statistical
fact that to every
Lucas Birch, there will was
always be a Byron Bunch.
Because marriage is
an addiction.
So that's why it is comedy.
Thank you very much.